not like her it's videos like this
that make me want to return our right to
vote
i don't people be like oh like you
wanted equal rights because i did this
video where i said that you know women
shouldn't be in combat and all these
guys are angry they're like no you
wanted this i'm like i didn't ask for
none of that
driving i don't even think i should have
a driver's license like no offense it's
just like not my forte that's like the
right to vote i give it up because women
trend toward communism like they vote
with fifi's like no thank you no thanks
especially like how many dumb women are
gonna be like you know what i'm gonna
vote for this lady just twerking on
tick-tock like that's
y'all
come on i'll take one for the team i'll
seriously i'll take one for the team
i'll take away our right to vote
to get the outcomes i want you know what
i mean
you're gonna go down for that you're
literally gonna go down i've said it so
many times
i've
i'm gonna take one for the team how they
voted for somebody with dementia you
know what i'm saying like what
like let me vote for somebody that won't
give me the the
what is it the the baby formula like you
know we're just not doing that good with
these decisions like i don't know
i mean we're back like let's let our
husbands vote for us
oh i'm tired with that
james is like solid guy yeah yeah james
james and i very much agree on all
things
in the political landscape
he's probably more conservative or he's
probably more
of a stickler than i am i kind of laugh
this stuff off he's like
it's it's
i'll let him vote for me for sure
should we start a movement return our
rights
yeah i mean i'm shooting i'm down like i
have all my girlfriend like many of my
girlfriends are coming out and they're
saying look like we just don't seem to
be voting well okay like no offense it's
not a forte we'd be voting based off of
feelings but you know what i found was
interesting too
is it's this new thing where women are
like oh yeah i'm queer and it's like
because that wasn't the tech talk like
i'm a black queer woman but one time i
went to the gym
and these other you know college fit
white women you know i'm in the midwest
so they were talking about like oh yeah
like i'm queer i'm like look
making out with your girlfriend at the
bar when you're drunk doesn't
necessarily make you queer you know what
i mean like i don't what is this like
i'm a woman also i'm queer like why do
you want to be included in everything
and that's women
yeah because no one because women don't
want to
feel like they're out of the party like
they want to be a part of everything and
um that was like a trend in college so
like if you made out remember katy perry
i kissed a girl and i like it like we
we've been there done that so like can
we just keep it pushing like why are we
still why are we trying to be queer
everyone like i don't understand next
you know it's like what's her name
what's that singer demi lovato who like
became non-binary overnight and she can
talk to aliens and like stuff like that
she was a beautiful woman
a beautiful woman
and then she went like non-binary queer
trans whatever like
and then just became weird like
literally the weirdest person
and speaks to it or sings to aliens so
i don't know
did we bring back exclusion bring back
exclusion
not everybody gets invited to the party
not everybody
well some of you were never not invited
to a party in high school and it shows
that's character building that's
character building
when they come up on monday and they say
wow that [ __ ] was lit and you say what
party
character building
bring back exclusion
uh yes this is why i love pearl did you
know about all that stuff that happened
to demi lovato have you been watching
no i mean every time i every time i talk
to her she's like crazier and crazier
well and not talk to her like hear about
her
i was gonna say you talked to her
one-on-one like pearls no no no
i sometimes i feel like i know these
people
right well her she od'd and she had a
stroke so i think that she just like
honestly took brain damage because like
after that she's coming up with all
types of things like for real for real
pearl like blair white has reviewed her
clips and she really was like singing to
aliens and then she was like talking to
a ghost i think or an alien she's like i
have experienced trauma too i'm like but
like in this dimension though like this
one this was the dimension
and over a certain age
i just feel like you can't blame your
trauma anymore like it's just
i don't know what age that is but it's
just like at some point you got to be
like you know what i think i just make
bad decisions
that's too hard for women to to get to
that point i was literally thinking
about that today it's like we've
we've gone to a point in society where
you can't even talk to a woman about
anything that she disagrees with or
she'll go crazy like she'll lose her
ever-loving mind and then
literally like hit you with all of these
attacks whatever she'll send her friends
to you too
and it's ridiculous like they act like
little children like throwing a
full-blown tantrum
at the mall and all you want to do is
slap him in the face like i'm so sorry
to break it to you you can't
you cannot
put your trauma on anyone else
sorry can't do it
do you did you guys hear about that one
time demi lovato tried to cancel an ice
cream shop because yes he had an eating
disorder and then she went in there and
i guess they had like gluten free and
dairy free ice cream and she flipped her
ish and posted it on twitter tried to
dox these people apologize the next day
like i'm sorry my bad you know i i'm
done i'm done with the level the
audacity
the audacity of the stages
okay
so the next story we're going to share
okay
another the audacity
so
there's two parts to this
but share system ally i'm so glad you
shot taught me how to share my screen
audio
yes any time so
so this is a reaction from chisholm
because i couldn't
oh my god
the name is right there okay well
i thought i thought i couldn't find the
tick tock
but it's right there anyways it's on the
right
so
oh wait i don't know i did part two we
got to do part one first
so this is a woman who thought it'd be a
good idea
to sleep with her daughter's baby daddy
now i don't
i don't know what world these women live
in where like you're competing with your
mom for guys
i never had this
we're just gonna watch the video waste
some time
let's get it this is what you do with my
mom are you serious
i know you're lying and you just sitting
there quiet you ain't got to say mom
really you ain't got to say really so
you just no i don't want to hear that
yeah i'ma put it on facebook i want
everybody to see the two
this is right here what they doing in my
bed
my bed i'm still your mother i don't
care who you are obviously you don't
care that i'm your daughter right you
over here sleeping with my baby daddy
that's my [ __ ] baby daddy you don't
clean because i'll be at work i'd be at
work you don't i'd be at work
like you don't treat him right what you
expect him to do you got a whole man you
talk about i don't treat you right oh
girl come on now taxi call the train get
on button